My dearest Lauren Lou,
From the day you were born you captured
our hearts with an infectious smile that
soon developed into the warmest hug.
I used to remind myself that the day
would come when I would find myself
missing you
the little girl who would sing around
the house or write plays for others to
perform; the girl who was at times so
hungry but unable to decide what she was
hungry for; the girl who adores her baby
sister
My dearest Lauren I appreciate your
integrity, your passion, and your love for
Jesus. I expect great things from you, not
great as defined by the world drunk on
its own materialism, but great on a
deeper level. I expect you to live
truthfully, to face your imperfections
head-on, to be real and authentic in your
relationships; I expect you to call home
I will close with some guidelines: life
is not fair
get used to it. Always treat people with
respect and be nice to everyone. Maintain
balance in your life.
Always keep your personal integrity, it
defines who you are. Do something with
your career that you're passionate about
never let money be the motivator for
what you decide to do: success is
determined by how you contribute to
making someone else's life better
my dear Lauren, today is one of the best
days of our lives. You have exceeded our
highest hopes and dreams. Thank you for
bringing so much joy into our lives
with all my love, your dad